non
je m'appelle et éric bellion je suis
navigateur depuis plus de dix ans je
démontre comment la diversité des
équipes est un facteur d'innovation et
de performance
pour cela j'utilise la course au large
car sur la mer on ne triche pas on est
obligé d'aller au fond des
problématiques humaines et de trouver
des solutions pour moi une équipe de
profils variés ira toujours plus loin
qu'un groupe de clones si elle est
soudée et bien manager
quand les hommes ne font qu'un autour
d'un projet commun le succès est garanti
en 2016 je vais participer au vendée
globe
la plus célèbre la plus exigeante et la
plus médiatisée des courses à la voile
un homme un bateau pour un tour du monde
sans escale et sans assistance
je vise plus que la victoire en
solitaire pour cette course mythique
avec vous je veux porter haut les
valeurs du vivre ensemble et de la
diversité humaine
le défi comme un seul homme c'est un
équipage de 20 entreprises qui vont
naviguer à mes côtés pendant les 22 mois
de préparation de la course
les collaborateurs de chaque entreprise
vont avec l'aide de nos équipes
réalisé cette vidéo de deux minutes
témoignant de leur expérience sur la
richesse de la diversité au sein de leur
entreprise pendant la course
les vidéos seront postés sur la
plateforme web comme un seul homme les
votes du public et d'un jury de
personnalités feront évoluer placement
en temps réel l'entreprise qui captera
le plus d'adhésion sera leader et son
drapeau sera hissé chaque jour sur mon
bateau en somme plus vos équipes
s'investissent plus votre visibilité
augmente
après la course c'est 100 films
représenteront une base de données
exceptionnelles au service du mieux
travailler ensemble sur le vendée globe
devenons le coup de coeur du public et
démontrons ensemble comme un seul homme
que la différence est une force
merci pour votre accueil
bonjour à tous 7
le projet vendée globe donc c'est en
2016 et ce en fait l'aboutissement d'une
démarche qui est à peu près 15 ans
maintenant et ce qui est drôle c'est que
cette démarche est là elle est née ici
enfin les nez un peu plus haut elle est
née dans la zone qu'a fait de l'om lyon
à une soirée où on picole un peu et en
fait j'ai rencontré deux amis qui
faisaient le m avec moi et en parlant en
buvant pendant cette soirée on s'est dit
qu'on avait le même rêve de gosse et que
ce rêve de gosse c'était faire le tour
du monde à la voile et on s'est dit bah
c'est fabuleux de se trouver on va se
faire une promesse c'était une promesse
d'ivrogne mais pas tant que ça puisque
on s'est promis qu'on ferait le tour du
monde après nos études
en fait on s'est retrouvé deux ans après
nos études on a travaillé on a pris un
petit appartement à paris
on a acheté une épave et en 2003 on est
parti trois ans faire tour du monde
autour du monde à la voile
moi qui avais ça a été une aventure
complètement initiatique à tous niveaux
je viens d'un milieu bourgeois j'ai fait
une école de commerce comme ça et
pendant trois ans je me suis clochardisé
complètement et pendant trois ans on a
partagé notre projet avec 45 jeunes
adultes infirmes moteurs cérébraux les
gens qu'on avait rencontré au début
parce qu'on n'avait pas envie de se
perdre pendant trois ans sans projet on
avait un peu la trouille de se perdre et
donc on a partagé le projet avec eux et
moi ça a été un bouleversement à tous
niveaux à tout étage et en rentrant je
me suis dit qu'un il fallait que je
vivre de ma passion la mer 2 il fallait
que je me serve de ce que j'avais appris
j'avais fait une belle école de commerce
j'avais été commercial je savais vendre
des choses et 3 je voulais faire avancer
le schmilblick
je voulais pas être un passager de la
planète et donc
je me suis mis à creuser la tête pour
savoir qu'est ce que je pouvais faire
après et je me j'ai constaté après mon
projet la façon dont on avait de traiter
le handicap en france et j'ai constaté
qu'on donnait un peu d'argent pour des
personnes handicapées
surtout pour qu'elle reste chez elle pas
beaucoup d'argent d'ailleurs et on donne
de l'argent à vie il ya que dans les
familles avec l'argent de poche on donne
de l'argent à vie à quelqu'un pour qu'il
fasse rien et là dans nos sociétés
françaises on donne de l'argent à vie à
des gens qui sont capables de travailler
capable d'apporter quelque chose à la
société mais surtout pour qu'elle reste
chez elle
pourquoi parce qu'on a peur d'évoluer on
a peur de remettre à plat nos façons de
faire c'est ça la vraie raison est donc
en 2007 avec un aventurier handicapés on
a lancé un nouveau projet s'appelait
défi intégration défi intégration c'est
simple on s'est vus dans un resto à
paris et on sur la nappe du restaurant
on a écrit notre équation magique qui
était un on va faire un équipage un
équipage de sportifs valides et
handicapés à parité 3-3 on va adapter un
bateau de course pour que 100 pour cent
de la main d'oeuvre soit accessible à
tous les équipiers trucs qu'elle ait
jamais été fait première mondiale et
troisièmement avec cet équipage bizarre
et ce bateau bizarre on va faire un
record à la voile parce que dans la tête
des gens dans la tête des entreprises de
nous tous un record à la voile c'est
fait pour dégâts 30-40 ans valide breton
voilà et nous on va démontrer que on est
différent mais qu en faisant les choses
différemment
on va être capable de d'être performant
et que le handicap rime pas avec à
capacité ça nous a mis trois ans et en
2010 on est détenteur du record
lorient île maurice en passant par le
cap de bonne espérance
avec cet équipage on est toujours
détenteur du record aujourd'hui si
michel desjoyeaux aussi mais évidemment
et coupe le temps en 2 1 et sur mais
personne n'a tenté ils doivent avoir la
trouille je pense mais résidant est
toujours détenteur mais on a démontré
que cette équipe était capable de faire
ça et on a pris l'entreprise
on a fait une démonstration c'est
l'entreprise elle adore la métaphore du
bateau pour parler
on ferme les écoutilles on est tous les
tous dans le même bateau
on regarde tous dans le même cap et
c'est cette aventure elle a été
extraordinaire mais il se trouve que moi
quand je mets le pied à l'île maurice en
2010 donc en novembre 2010 je me dis
mais plus jamais ça plus jamais ça
est-ce que autant la navigation s'est
extrêmement bien passé j'ai jamais aussi
bien navigué de ma vie avec cette équipe
mais autant les trois ans de préparation
était un calvaire
parce qu'on est rentré dans tous les
écueils possibles du travail et du vivre
ensemble quand on est différent et ils
sont nombreux ces écueils
je vous en citer quelques-uns
l'angélisme la pitié le fait de ne pas
faire la différence entre la personne et
son handicap
la personne et sa différence moi il m'a
fallu à peu près un an pour digérer
l'histoire à force de conférences de
formations et puis ça a été dur parce
que remplissent comme vous êtes manager
ça va être visible donc vous est visé
donc ça a été difficile et au bout d'un
an j'ai digéré l'histoire et je me suis
dit mais cette aventure elle est belle
le record est beau parce qu'il symbolise
quelque chose de fort pour le monde de
l'entreprise on montre que le handicap
en soi et pas un problème pour
l'intégration et que si c'est possible
sur un bateau de course c'est possible
dans l'entreprise mais surtout ce qui
est intéressant c'est tout le
cheminement qu'on a fait pour arriver à
une navigation est un succès alors quand
on peut pas parler des heures je vous
garde et deux anecdotes que j'ai revu
après ce projet la première c'est au
moment de partir il fallait qu'on règle
un problème qui était le problème de la
sécurité
comme on n'avait jamais imaginé qu'une
personne handicapée puisse faire partie
d'un équipage de course au large
fallait tout adapté et notamment la
sécurité et la survie commence sauver
c'est le bateau coule
1 comment il y 3 y ait quelqu'un qui a
les paraplégiques ou tétraplégiques sait
pas faire et on allait voir la marine
nationale pour ça parce que c'est des
pros lé la sécurité et au début un peu
provocant et m'ont dit écoutez monsieur
bellion nous dans un harry nationale on
n'a pas de personnes handicapées on n'en
veut pas on fait la guerre
ils ont raison ils font la guerre donc
ils ont besoin de gens avec des bras
parfait des yeux parfait des jambes
parfaites donc le le le
le processus de formation le la
formation n'était pas du tout fait pour
des personnes handicapées et en
réfléchissant et 110 on a envie de vous
aider donc on va faire en sorte que
cette formation soit accessible et en
travaillant avec les pros et sont rendu
compte d'une chose assez incroyable
c'est que depuis 50 ans que le programme
existe coc sans le centre d'entraînement
au survie à la survie et au sauvetage de
l'aéronautique navale et donc qui depuis
50 ans il forme des pilotes et du
personnel navigant qui se veut
poursuivre le jour où il se crashe dans
l'eau en avion ou en hélicoptère et en
fait il n'avait jamais imaginé qu'une
personne après un crash puisse se
blesser tout leur protocole de formation
était fait pour des gens qui sort de
l'eau va nickel je saute dans le dans le
bebook je me fais hélitreuiller ya aucun
problème
il n'avait jamais imaginé ça et le fait
d'accueillir un équipage d'un de bras
cassés de blessés professionnels ils
sont dit mais merde c'est vrai
évidemment que quand un avion se crashe
ou un hélicoptère ce crash dont on peut
se briser les doigts peuvent crever les
yeux on peut se rassurer le bassin et en
fait on s'est retrouvé à un moment une
semaine à passer une semaine ensemble et
on a pu se demander qui était les former
et qui étaient les formateurs c'est à
dire qu'on a été formé certes mais nous
on a formé avec nos blessés
la marine nationale et son corps 2013 à
sauver une vie un pilote a réussi à ce
crash a réussi à se crasher sur il s'est
crashé en méditerranée sur un super
étendard
il a réussi à enlever son harnais en
utilisant la paume de ses mains plutôt
que ses doigts et c'est quelque chose
qu'on avait montré dans les vidéos
petite anecdote qui vous démontre que en
se fixant une contrainte forte qui est
la soi-disant fragilité contraintes
physiques et bien on innove et on re
découvrir que l'innovation ne vient que
d'une chose de la contrainte l'art vient
du cadre première découverte
deuxième chose sur ce projet ça a été
difficile humainement
parce que on a recruté d'abord des
personnes handicapées et on n'a pas
d'abord cherché des marins
et en fait quand on cherche des gens
pour un projet il faut s'attacher à au
fondamental pas la différence
superficielles les différences
superficiel c'est le fait de se tenir
debout ou assis l'âge le sexe la couleur
de la peau etc
le fondamental c'est quoi c'est
l'adhésion au projet
celle envie celle à partager la même
notion de sacrifice d'engagement pour
arriver à l'objectif c'est le respect du
leadership etc
il en fait c'est ce qu'il faut aller
chercher ce fondamental et le
superficiel en fait c'est différent cela
à partir du moment au parc on partage le
fondamental elles sont une richesse
qu'on va donner ou à la performance
collective et anecdotes dans cet
équipage on a recruté une personne
aveugle il y avait une personne aveugle
qui faisait tout comme tout le monde
totalement barré vous imaginez la gueule
des marins professionnels quand je leur
ai dit que j'allais embarquer une
personne aveugle on dit eric déjà les
personnes handicapées c'est un défi de
fou alors une personne aveugle c'est un
défi dans le défi tu vas tu arrêter ou
c'est pas possible
une personne aveugle n'a rien à faire
sur un bateau de course c'est trop
dangereux et il se trouve que cette
personne aveugle en fait c'était olivier
et olivier il avait vraiment envie
il avait les capacités pour le faire et
en petite anecdote on va partir et lui
avaient un peu la trouille
parce que c'était pas facile était
aveugle devait barré comme tout le monde
et il se confie à isabelle autissier qui
est une grande navigatrice qui nous
aidaient et en partant il avait
lautissier lui dit mais arrête d'avoir
peur de façon tepa brunet fesses alors
lié web en des fesses puis garde ça en
lui et puis il nous le dit mais non
qu'on croit pas trop
et en fait on a compris au fur et à
mesure la navigation le carde olivier
bas au début était vraiment nul vraiment
en dessous de l'autre quart de l'autre
équipe séoul et qui navigue et puis
progressivement à la moitié sont devenus
pareil et puis après le quart d'olivier
est devenu le meilleur et olivier devenu
le meilleur barreur du bateau
pourquoi vous savez on a fait un test
sur les plus grands marins du monde
savoir pourquoi hibbard aussi bien alors
d'abord on leur a mis des moufles sur
les mains ça
disons que ça vient ça vient de la pulpe
des doigts le touché de bars etc
hilmar est super bien on leur a mis un
masque bar est super bien on leur a mis
des grosses gouttes avec des grosses
semelles en caoutchouc sur les pieds en
disant ça vient peut-être des pieds les
ont barré super bien on leur a mis un
coussin sous les fesses il paraît comme
des patates à bateaux ça se bat repas
etc les yeux et on a découvert ça on a
redécouvert ça ça se barre avec les
fesses ça vous épate ans en fait une
question d' assiettes à bateau vous
garder la vitesse maximum quand vous
garder la même assiette et sa personne
n'aurait donné sa chance à olivier mais
lui il avait un handicap qui était sa
principale chance nous on a un handicap
ses devoirs donc on veut pas faire ce
travail extraordinaire qu'il a dû faire
mais lui comme il voit pas il a été
obligé de travailler l'assiette du
bateau et il est devenu un excellent
barreur donc fin 2010 je regarde le
temps en plus fin 2010 je digère tout
l'histoire je vois tout ce qui a été
intéressant les étapes à peu près pour
créer une équipe riche de ses
différences équipe devient performante
je me dis ben il faut valider ça en vrai
voir si ça marche
donc je vends le bateau tout adapté
j'achète un volvo ocean race est un
bateau de 20 mètres en kevlar un matt 30
mètres une formule 1 des mers pour une
course qui a lieu tous les trois ans les
deux dernières éditions il y avait que
des hommes occidentaux entre 25 et 40
ans bodybuildé quoi et non ce débat sur
ce bateau on va recruter des gens pour
leur différence des hommes des femmes
des jeunes des vieux des personnes
valides et personnes handicapées
à bord il y avait un analyste financier
à la bnp paribas est un gars des
banlieues et ils parlent ils ont tous le
fondamental en en commun on commence à
naviguer on s'entraîne fin 2013 ont fait
une course mythique qui s'appelle le
fastnet race c'est la fin de notre séant
dans notre saison de navigation
fastnet c'est l'équivalent de la coupe
du coupe d'europe de foot version voile
si vous voulez tous les deux ans les
meilleurs marins du monde se regroupe en
angleterre pour faire cette course qui
dure entre trois et six jours nous on
est dans une catégorie reine la
catégorie des maxi yachts débattu de des
bateaux de plus 20 mètres est avec nous
il ya que des tycoons qui payent des
bateaux des fortunes qui recrute les
meilleurs marins du monde pour ramener
le graal chez eux et nous on est le
bateau associatif avec sais pas trop
quoi dedans et sur 18 bateaux dans la
catégorie ont fait 8e et à plymouth
quand les pros nous découvrent voit le
bateau qui les a battues plutôt bizarre
et il découvre pas de descendre du
bateau un gars qui dépit sa canne
d'aveuglé
un autre qui montrent son fauteuil
roulant toutes des filles pas possible
pas de fille des seniors un peu
bedonnant et la première leur première
action c'est une colère sourde en disant
mais c'est pas possible c'est pas fait
battre par ça et si et en plus ils
observent un truc assez incroyable c'est
que cet équipage
il se jette à l'eau de bonheur à
plymouth je vous préviens l'été à la 15°
l'eau il ya du courant c'est vraiment
très désagréable le vainqueur du fastnet
s'est pas jetée à l'eau mais nous nous
tous les 12 membres de l'équipage
on s'est jeté à l'eau de bonheur comme
si on avait gagné la course comme si on
avait vécu une aventure de nos vies mais
est ce qu'on a vécu l'aventuré notre vie
parce qu'on a souffert tous ensemble on
a souffert tous ensemble vers un
objectif qu'on savait comme un once avec
tout le monde donner le maximum pour
atteindre cet objectif
ce qui nous a permis de créer une
cohésion d'atteindre une performance
collective extrêmement forte puisque
comme tout le monde travailler au
maximum de ses possibilités
et bien cette performance collective n'a
jamais cessé de de croître et enfin on a
pu exulter en équipe parce qu'on avait
souffert et on avait pris du plaisir
ensemble et je vais terminer là dessus
l'idée de ce vendée globe c'est d'aller
raconter ça au grand public le vendée
globe c'est 65 % des français qu'on suit
vie les la dernière édition
c'est un événement médiatique
extraordinaire de 100 jours on peut
raconter une belle histoire et notre
idée c'est de raconter que on se trompe
aujourd'hui complètement sur la façon
dont on traite la diversité humaine dans
l'entreprise ou dans notre communauté on
la traite que sur le plan du civisme de
l'humanisme d'ul sur le plan fiscal il
sur le plan légal c'est une erreur
totale
je ne pouvais jamais en chantant chanter
les gens par ça et les gens qui décident
les managers les recruteurs s'en foutent
ce qui est intéressant c'est de dire que
la diversité humaine c'est une
formidable occasion pas cher même qui
rapportent de l'argent
c'est que les entreprises payent des
taxes c'est une formidable occasion et
c'est la seule source d'innovation deux
performances parce que c'est la vraie
performance collective et donc de
bien-être personnel et d'enrichissement
collectif le projet ils s'appellent
comme un seul homme
stand assouan en anglais le émilion et
partenaires et vous allez voir bientôt
je vous remercie